so we are live now
uh hello everybody welcome to the second
talk in the series of talks
uh surrounding like the
robust um
speech challenge and the second talk it
will be given by jeremy and ray who work
as machine learning engineers at kenzo
technologies
um they worked on the pi ctc decode
library which is now integrated into the
transformers library and enables you to
improve like the
automatic speech recognition
and to tell you more about it i give the
word to you
all right uh
yeah thanks for for asking us to do this
talk uh i'm jeremy lopez and as you said
today we're gonna be talking to you
about pi cd cd code and some stuff about
special text decoding
uh a bit about us so so we're both ml
engineers at kensho and kensho is an ai
company that was founded in 2013 and
then acquired by the financial company s
p global in 2018
and since then we've been powering uh
a lot of snps
um uh ai and and tech
uh advancements and also we've you've
gotten access to s p's huge amounts of
data that we could then use to power the
different things that we work on uh one
of the products that we offer is called
kensho scribe which is a speech text uh
solution that produces transcripts from
audio
um it's the way this talk is gonna work
is i'm gonna give you a brief
introduction to ctc decoding um and then
uh then ray's gonna give you a
walkthrough and some examples of the pi
ctcd code package um and we also we gave
a longer version of this talk a couple
days ago at for the hugging face
audio
ml audio ml study group also you want to
know more there's also that video
available which is
about twice as long as this talk
so for the first part i'm going to talk
to you about uh first an overview of a
generic speech-to-text pipeline that
you're likely to see
and then uh a review of ctc encoding and
species text and then talk about how to
actually
a little bit about how to decode ctc
encoded output
uh so first of all um a review of a
standard kind of architecture um so
obviously for
for speech to text you want to start
with an audio sample
so like an mp3 or a wav file and
probably the first thing you want to do
is to perform some sort of
pre-processing
to get features for every chunk of audio
that's some number of milliseconds long
and once you have these features uh you
typically will pass the generated per
time set features into some sort of
neural net model like wave to vector
citrinet
which gives you back some per time step
logic matrix
and this logic matrix typically will
then give you soft max logics predicting
character probabilities for each slice
and time from through your your audio
um and often these characters are going
to be actual characters like like you
know latin letters but they it's they
could be something else but you know
typically there's it's roughly you know
predicting um
regular regular characters
i'll but these are character
probabilities that have a twist there um
so as i said the audio is typically
sliced into evenly spaced chunks of time
um and you'll so you'll predict
all these logits for each slice um and
this means that any kind of output
length you get from this is going to be
proportional to your
audio length and not your text length
which is a complication that
is the reason why you have to go to ctc
encoding which which i'll talk about in
a bit
uh but once you get these generated
pretensive logics typically what you
want then um is that you need to have
some sort of decoder that takes this
matrix and
returns some sort of hopefully human
readable text
and so this is what we're going to be
talking about today
which is how roughly how this works
um so uh i'll give you a review of ctc
encoding uh if you haven't seen it
before so this stands for connectionist
temporal classification
um and the reason why you need to have
some sort of encoding is there are some
challenges in decoding um these logits
so typically you'll have many more time
steps than predicted characters uh the
reason for this is that
you need to make sure you have enough
slices in time that you could actually
have your output be long enough
regardless of how fast someone is
speaking or the kinds of words they're
saying
but also we have things like duplicated
characters in actual words like in the
english word hello there's two l's and
the reason why that's important is that
when you um
actually get the output of of um
of this whole process you need some way
of collapsing repeated characters
without also eliminating duplicates uh
so for example if you have these two um
if you have these two outputs uh both of
these
clearly represent the english word hello
and so when you decode this kind of uh
string they should both decode to the
same exact thing and the reason why you
can get this is that you know someone
speaks that nor you're fairly fast maybe
you just automatically get out the word
as your output but if someone speaks
much slower uh potentially you'll have
you know several copies of each letter
in your in your output and so when you
decode this you know this is still the
english word hello just said much slower
uh so you have you know several um
slices for each each actual character
and so what you can do here is you could
add a new character to the alphabet that
represents a break between characters
often it's gonna be denoted like
something like pad or just an underscore
and so when you have these repeated
characters you potentially can try to
have your model insert um this break
character in between the l's and then
you can decode these with a two-step
process of first removing any duplicate
characters and then removing this extra
ctc break character
and that will take these two strings and
produce in the end the english word
hello for both of them
um and so this is what you do once you
have a string you want to decode but
like i said what happens is that um the
audio models you'll typically you'll
often be using
um will output this logic matrix and so
you have to then now take a logic matrix
and produce a string in a cdc encoded
string that can then be decoded um so uh
we need to decode this
cdc encoded output so there is an easy
way to do this a very simple way that
you could probably code up in just a few
lines which is to do a greedy decoding
that takes the arg max of each uh time
step see so you go through your logic
matrix and at each time you just take
the most likely character
um and then from that string you can
then run this two-step process of
removing the repeated characters and
then removing the ctc uh character break
character and that gives you a way to go
from this matrix to a string
and this potentially um is often decent
but it's probably not optimal there's a
number of issues that you can run into
so like in english homophones are fairly
common so you can say run into something
like the
word that the noun not versus the word
not meaning negation both of these are
pronounced the same way so you invite so
a model might actually you know confuse
them
there's also just misspellings that can
happen
um and many lot new kinds of small
errors so for example in english uh f
and ph and gh and so on can all give you
the exact same sound so you can then ask
yourself well what happens if i run the
word for through my model
and it wants to output the text p h o r
you know that would be pronounced for
but it's not an actual word um so if
you're an engineer like an ml engineer
and a data scientist you might want to
think well what if i then to correct
this i just collect a lot more data i
retrain all my models and see if that
fixes it um and so that
sounds reasonable but there's a number
of issues there as well uh where
that can be very expensive and that can
be very very time consuming to actually
collect data to retrain models and even
then in the end you might actually find
out you haven't actually fixed these
kinds of issues
so that you actually might need to
rethink how you're doing things a bit so
we can consider two different things so
first can we inject more information
about language to try to guide the
decoding process to give you more
natural sounding language and second can
you use a better decoding strategy so i
don't want to go into details um but
this is got uh we go into more of this
in the longer version of the talk
but you can use beam search instead of
this greedy decoding to consider
multiple possible decodings so you can
build up uh
you know different outputs
and try to consider you as several of
the higher weighted ones to try to give
you more options to give you better
better results but i'm going to go into
more detail a bit more detail about
language modeling
uh so ultimately what you want to do to
try to guide the decoding is you want to
be able to score how likely a given text
is given that you have this logic matrix
that represents what the audio was but
also you probably have a lot of text
that gives you some sense of what normal
language looks like and we can use this
to try to remove improbable parts of the
predicted text so even if the audio
sounds a lot like something that is very
unnatural sounding we can then hopefully
remove it or down weight it based on the
fact that we know that maybe this is not
normal sounding text there's something
that's you know not quite as highly
weighted but is much better
and so one common way you can do this is
with an engram language model um and so
these are something that were is uh
they're fairly uh traditional and i
think it was existed long before deep
learning became very popular uh but
there are probabilistic models that
where if you given some sequence of size
n minus one you can try to predict what
the nth word is or what the probability
of the nth word being some particular
word and by doing this you can try to
identify improbable sequences of text
that might need to be changed and so
again this is used in conjunction with
logits so that way you combine both your
audio and your sense of what that
natural language looks like uh to get
you the best possible output
uh so for the purposes here a language
model is basically just something that
you take some proposed text you put it
through your model and you get some
score likelihood out so for example if
you have the english text the angry
brown cat you know that sounds pretty
like much like natural english so
probably you want to have a decently
high score so maybe your language model
assigns some probability or likelihood
of say 0.4 or something for that
but if you have the text the angry cat
brown um that's much less natural
sounding in english so that probably
gives you a much smaller um
result it's probably not zero since
there could be cases where that text
could appear in in actual english but it
was just not as common as the previous
text so you'll give it a smaller smaller
probability
um so for a more concrete example you
could have a bigram language models this
is an n equals two language model and so
if you throw in some text like the first
line from a tale of two cities uh what
the probability of this text would be is
um just the combination the
probabilities of each word
given that the what the previous word
was um so in biograms you only include
the the
single word uh prior to each word uh and
so then the bi-gram model just needs to
then memorize probabilities for these
pairs of words um and you can go to
higher and higher ends you can go to n
equals three or four but you can't go
that much higher than probably you know
n equals four or five uh just because
at some point you just don't have enough
samples of you know a word with
five or six um
previous words before so you just can't
get good probabilities for those
and so the way you could potentially
incorporate this is that as you're
decoding
a piece of text um you can then build it
up like in beam search you um uh you
iteratively build up your text and at
each point you could ask yourself well
what is the probability of this text
given the logic so what does the audio
say and then add in what does the
language model say
and the idea here is that if you have
very
uh strongly disfavored text you could
have a large penalty that goes into your
your score for this text and if you have
very you know natural sounding text you
have a much smaller penalty and by doing
this you could then guide yourself to to
try to
um choose mostly things that sound the
most like natural language
um and so that's all i want to talk
about for for this first part um like i
said there's if you want to know more
there's a longer version of this talk uh
but just in conclusion ctc and code is a
pretty common way for audio models
you're likely to see to output character
information and then the pi cdc code
package the package that you hear about
next decode cdc include logistics using
beam search um and also allowing for you
to add a language model to help assist
your decoding to give you more natural
sounding output
and now from here
i'll let ray give you more information
about the pi ctc decode package
awesome thank you jeremy
so on to pi ct city code
first of all i've included a few
links here to places you might find more
information obviously the first is the
actual
um
pi ccd code repo and i've also included
a link to the demo code that's used to
generate the examples here and of course
we gave a more detailed version of this
talk with more information and i've
included the link there
um so pi cdc code is a package that we
developed at kensho
to decode ctc encoded logits it's
implemented in python which means that
it's fairly simple to code and also
makes it fairly easy to extend with new
features and hopefully easy to use and
common ml workflows although i don't
want to you know pat ourselves on the
back too much
and everything that jeremy discussed in
part one is implemented we use beam
search to to determine the
quasi-optimal output text we offer
language model support with kennel m as
our package for language models on the
back end and of course you can do greedy
decoding
if you just don't include a language
model and use a beam width of one
and we also offer some additional
features so the first thing that we
offer is hot word boosting
basically you can
add hot words as a list and then boost
the probabilities in the n-gram language
model of each hot word appearing this is
extremely useful when speech conditions
might be different from
those that your model was trained in an
example of this is early in 2020 when
covid and coronavirus became extremely
common in the english dialect but there
weren't a lot of training samples that
actually contain these words
and hot words is uh implemented pretty
straightforwardly we just take the
probability that jeremy talked about in
the first part and in addition to the
probability from the logits and the
probability of the text from the
language model we add some
flat bonus
if
the the latest word is a hot word
we also offer
uh comparable speed to all of the other
decoding packages that i've previously
used
and we achieved this despite being coded
in python
by aggressive caching and extensive use
of beam pruning so we reject any beams
that
achieve a particularly low probability
at any point and we also cache partial
results during calculations so we don't
need to continue calling the language
model for very similar strings
i don't know if i can actually say the
package we were using previously i don't
want to throw any shade but uh you can
see here that we we achieve a
actually faster run time than the
package uh while also maintaining uh and
even beating our previous wrs
and of course there's lots more that we
want to do with this package if you have
any suggestions or would like to see any
features feel free to submit a
feature request on the github
so let's get started with actually
implementing pi cccd code uh it is a
python package so pip install seems like
a good place to start
but jokes aside to start using pi ctcode
effectively you really need four things
uh you need a text corpus um ideally
you'd want the same text corpus that was
used to train your link acoustic model
to train your language model you need an
acoustic model
we handle both biparent coded and
character-based acoustic models and
if you're looking to use a pre-trained
model here hugging face probably have
all of your needs covered
uh you need to have access to the
vocabulary set for the above model and
then of course you need countlem so that
you can train your engram model on your
text corpus
so
where would you look for a data set the
data set we used in the demo repo is
speech speech
it's 5 000 hours of financial audio and
associated transcripts
which is approximately five times the
size of library speech i highly
recommend it
although this is a bit of self-promotion
uh species speech is
consists of company earnings calls that
are split into short chunks to allow for
easy training of speech recognition
systems uh we've got almost 50 000
unique speakers with a variety of
accents and speaking conditions and also
the training vow sets are the result of
manual transcription which means that
there's
very well normalized text that has very
polished orthography
for an acoustic model again
we
can handle both by pairing code or
character based
and
the only thing you need here is the
vocabulary set that the acoustic model
uses
i've included a snippet here
using the hugging face wave to vec
base model this is the model i use for
the demo examples that i'll talk about
shortly
and then
the the final thing that you need is a
catalan model
and
again canalem is a python model
instructions for training your your
model on a text corpus such as species
speech are included in the demo repo
and i can't stress enough that matching
vocabulary sets is critical
even a very slight mismatch and the
characters used to train the language
model can lead to some very very strange
behavior on the back end
so let's get started
the first thing you need to do is build
a build your actual decoder
it takes the vocab the candlemodel
location and some params
and then you can decode an actual logic
matrix just by calling decode
and let's uh let's look at some samples
to get a feel for how
language models actually work in
practice i tried to pick a spread of
examples
including somewhere the language model
is very effective and somewhere it is
not and hopefully this gives you a good
idea of the kinds of errors that
language models tend to fix and the
kinds of areas that they might introduce
and also how to tune them
again all the the code is available
so let's start with a sample where the
language model performs pretty well
and here's the audio i also want to
remind everyone that any forward-looking
statements made during this call are
subject to risks and uncertainties the
most important of which are described in
our press release and sec filings
so this is a pretty straightforward
sample the audio quality is quite good
and so we would sort of expect any
acoustic model to perform fairly well
and indeed if we look at the greedy
decoding for the sample the language
model does perform quite well the only
two mistakes it makes are at the very
end instead of press release it says
press release and instead of sec filings
it says scc filings
so of course these are the sorts of
areas that we would expect a language
model to be able to address extremely
adequately because the phrase press
release is very common especially in
financial corpi as is sec filings and
indeed if we pass this through a decoder
trained on speedy speech it fixes both
of these errors without an issue
but now let's look at a sample where the
language model performs a little bit
less well
and here is the audio for that
thank you ivan i'm now going to look in
a bit more detail at what is as ivan
said a good set of results with better
top line performance margin expansion
and increased cash flow
so again this is a fairly clear audio
sample and we would hopefully expect an
acoustic model to perform fairly well on
this and if we look at the actual
greedy decoding it does indeed perform
fairly well in this the only mistake it
makes is at the end
instead of cash flow being two words
it's agglomerated into a single word
unfortunately if we pass this through a
language model with
default parameters
instead of the initial phrase thank you
ivan
we get back thank you even
and this is
an unfortunate error
excuse me because we we sort of expect
that
um
a language model will return something
that's more understandable english and
thank you even
is not even correct english um
and this is probably because you know
even is much more common than ivan is in
any engram
model uh but despite you know these
sorts of errors that are introduced it's
worth noting that language models are
still very useful uh we see a pretty
significant improvement in wr on on our
internal work
and this is even with a very large and
highly trained acoustic model so they
can be useful in in almost any
speech-tech scenario of course this
doesn't change the fact that they still
introduce these errors so how can we
address areas that the language model
introduces
so we have two options with the package
the first is we can use our hot words
feature from before
and boost hot words for things that may
be specific to our prediction domain
so things like names such as ivan for
people on a call that we know are on the
call words like covid that may be common
in in current speech but not in our
training corpus or we can adjust the
parameters to sort of increase and
decrease the weight on language model to
try and
capture as much of the benefits without
introducing as many of these errors so
let's try hotword boosting on our
previous sample
and hotwood boosting is very
straightforward to implement basically
you take a list and you can pass it to
your decoder.code call
with some weight this uh
increases the score
by you know whatever weight you pass it
to
and on our previous example we have the
correct ground truth and the correct
greedy decoding and now if we pass it
with the hot words instead of changing
the first thank you ivan it actually
fixes it and in addition to that it'll
improve the wr of the sample because it
fixes the error where cash flow is one
word
properly separating it into two words
uh so this is very useful in many common
transcription scenarios uh
including in a lot of production
scenarios where you might need to adjust
your model without retraining the whole
thing
um but sometimes this isn't enough so
let's look at our our second method of
improving language models which is
parameter chaining uh so pi ctc code
offers two main tunable params there are
also you know a few others that are are
possible but these are the two most
important
so alpha is basically the weight on the
language model versus the logits and
beta is a constant and it's hard to sort
of get an intuition for what adding a
constant does but more or less
uh in my experience it makes the model
more likely to
add or subtract words during training
it's important to note that when doing
any tuning like this that it's really
really easy to leak information if you
tune these parameters on your validation
set and then score them on the same
validation set you'll get very inflated
wer scores
so when if you're setting up a pipeline
like this you need to make sure that you
pull some sort of parameter tuning
holdout out of your training set maybe a
very small fraction of it and then the
rest of your training set can be
passed to your acoustic language models
for training
and your validation set should be
completely separate from these
and also if you're doing this sort of
tuning it's really important to have a
visual check sometimes if you wait the
language model too highly even if you
get a good wr you can get samples that
are
really really bad when humans look at
them just because the language model
will sometimes unilaterally decide that
something should be changed
so let's look at a sample for this
here's the audio
whereas then
in the industrial cranes and crane
components business units
let's listen to that one more time
whereas then
in the industrial cranes and crane
components business units
and this is a much more difficult audio
sample than the previous two uh this is
the correct transcription but when we
pass it to an acoustic model it has a
pretty hard time figuring out what
exactly is happening
you can see that it's a little confused
at the start the first phrase is jumbled
and then instead of cranes and crane
components we get grains and crane
components and if we pass it to a
language model with sort of standard
parameters
well
where it fixes the first error it
doesn't actually identify that
industrial grains and grain components
is probably not very likely english
i don't know why people would be talking
about grain components but if you
increase the weight on the language
model
and then run it again it eventually gets
to the point where it identifies that
grains is not really
in an industrial or component based item
and it corrects grains to cranes
and you can actually get it to
fix both the first cranes and the second
crane if you turn up the language model
high enough but
uh it starts to degrade performance in
other areas so i've left it at this
middle ground for the example
um again i can't stress enough that
ensure when you're training these that
you don't have any leakage with your
validation or you'll
you'll have a bad time
and that's all that we wanted to talk
about today
i hope you
sort of got a feel for what pi ccd code
can do and i hope that you uh get the
opportunity to use it in some of your
own speech text adventures
and i think we can we can pass it back
to
um
the android for questions or comments
a lot for the great talk um i think we
have a couple of minutes to answer a few
questions um
so far i haven't seen any question in
the chat but uh feel free to post one
uh if you have any um maybe in the
meantime since this is like a pretty
practical challenge that like the
participants of like the robust uh
speech challenge are facing do you have
any like practical tips on how you would
approach such a problem
like if you need to to build a speech
recognition system for like a rare
language say
jeremy do you want to take this
um yeah so i think for for yeah it's
like a rare language um i would say this
decoding um process probably is going to
be most effective for
certainly alphabetic type languages so
for something that's less
um
alphabetically like a language like
chinese i would i i haven't tried it out
but i would suspect that decoding would
be much less effective because you have
you know a character set of thousands of
characters and they're not really
phonetic um
but but also i think
if it's a language that you know i mean
this is something that you know even
trying out greedy decoding first to see
how
if you have a good audio model see how
it works
and then um
you know if you're able to collect a lot
of of text you're just training a
language model and throwing that in it
should be fairly easy
uh
to do um
and yeah but i think a big thing for for
language is just whenever you do this
just make sure you're
doing some
manual checking of things especially if
you're trying to tune parameters just to
make sure there's this uh embarrassment
score that ray mentioned which is not
really a a technical term but just
make sure that you're not making a lot
of really bad looking errors that maybe
don't get captured in traditional
metrics like word error rate
because i think i think humans will be
very
sensitive to pretty subtle language
errors
awesome thanks
um
still don't see any questions
maybe we wait
a couple of more minutes if um
[Music]
any any question pops up
yeah i think we're we're also almost
that time so
are there additional events following
this one
um that's
all the talks for today there are going
to be two more talks tomorrow um as far
as i know one uh from mozilla and
another one from meta ai about
data sets and automatic speech
recognition
very cool
so if there are no more questions i
thank you a lot for your nice
presentation and
wish you a nice evening or a nice day
thank you thank you and uh thank you for
setting all this up appreciate it
there's one question so maybe we can
answer that one
um is it possible to replace your
language model with a transform based
one
within your library
so this is something that is currently
in the pipeline for us um
we've been looking at at implementing
some transformer based language models
ourselves but it is not yet available in
pi ct cd code but it is something to
look for in the you know coming months
yeah this is all something that one of
the advantages of using python means
that you know modifications like this
are very should be very easy to do
cool yeah i think that um
transformer based language models also
bring a whole different set of
challenges especially to production
systems um just in terms of speed and
it's an additional complex model to to
maintain so there are benefits and and
drawbacks to doing so
that makes sense
so thanks a lot for your presentation
and uh
enjoy your day
bye everybody
thank you